let me see if i can um follow along with
you right the first thing i'm going to
do is it's not a quadratic i'm going to
turn it into one okay i'm going to
reduce it down so here is my
substitution okay now by the way this
step as with many steps it's kind of
like
i'm trying to think through what i'm
doing but as you get more comfortable
with this you don't have to say
explicitly you're doing it you can do
some of these steps in your head as you
become more familiar with them okay so
i'm going to write my
new equation in here
that's that again it's one i've chosen
which is easy to factorize what's the
pair of numbers i'm after
minus
three minus two positive three will that
work for me when i do minus two plus
three that's going to give me one right
which is supposed to be this number in
here right so it's not quite matching up
i need a different pair of factors it's
gonna be quite yeah
um
minus one six and minus one well six and
minus one do it for me when you add them
six
plus negative one do you get five
you do right and when you do six times
negative one do you get minus six
yeah you do it checks out okay so
therefore rather than this i'm going to
go 6 and negative 1 so i get u plus 6.
u minus 1 equals 0. are you happy with
that
okay so now i can go ahead and solve
minus 1.
sorry positive one
or negative six okay
yeah i mean u squared plus five u
squared why is it five u squared oh
sorry yeah that's wrong
thanks okay so i've done my now i've
done my substitution correctly i've
factorized i've gotten a pair of
solutions out for you okay so now i have
to go back don't i i have to go back to
here and i have to say x squared instead
of u all right so there's my one all my
negative six now once you get to this
point you might raise an eyebrow right
and think hold on
something a bit strange is going to
happen here
it doesn't start off too bad if you just
imagine x squared equals one and that's
all you have what solutions are you
going to get out of that
you're just going to get plus or minus
the square root of one which happens to
be one right so no big deal okay
but then you get to this next part
and you say hold on a second
there's no number at least not that
we're familiar with there's no number
you can square no real number that when
you square it gives you a
negative right because if you take the
square root of 6
if you square that guy you won't get
negative 6 you'll get 6 right if you
take
the negative square root of 6
if you square that you're still in
trouble because that double negative
will cancel and you'll still get
positive 6.
there's nothing we can do to come up
with an answer for this right so
therefore out of the 1 we get plus minus
1
out of the negative 6 though
it doesn't actually contribute any
solutions that's it i'm finished even
though we expected and it's a good read
with good reason we expected four
solutions right
we've only gotten two and that does
happen sometimes that's fine okay in
fact you can it doesn't take that much
effort to imagine if i shuffled around
my numbers a little bit
if i had two negative numbers here like
say negative 1 or negative 6
what would that mean for this final
answer here how many solutions would
there be
there wouldn't be any solutions that i
can deal with in these kinds of numbers
right because there's no numbers i can
square to get to negative 1 and no
numbers i can square to get to negative
6 at least not on my graph okay now just
out of the sake of
curiosity just so you can see what this
means
what this would look like is square root
of two is about 1.4 okay so you're going
to get a graph that looks something like
this
plus 18
yeah okay
something like that for this because
you've got a higher power up here it
just wiggles more right just like a
parabola wiggles once and it just goes
off this guy wiggles a few more times
okay um here what's going to happen
because you only got two solutions
you'll get a shape kind of like this
what's this plus or minus one um
okay it still wiggles the wiggles around
right but you see how i've got one two
three four solutions here but over here
i've only got two one two it just means
this wiggle happens too high or too low
or something else so that it never
actually intersects okay